[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
doors I first think of a Dear John and
Hank it's a comedy podcast for two
brothers answer your questions give you
to ease advice and bring you all the
week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon John
I was recently in Jamaica and I got a
pie a piece of pie it was it was a
dollar fifty and then I went to the
Turks and Caicos and I got some pie and
it was $2.00 mm-hmm these are the
Pirates of the Caribbean I mean that
joke like your level of enthusiasm
leaves a bit to be desired does it sound
like maybe I performed that joke a
number of times while on tour it does
but mostly it sounds like you're very
tired I am very tired John I have a cold
and the cough and I want to sleep but
also I want to make a podcast with you
so I had to choose and I chose this one
well Hank I have some great news for you
some really heartwarming uplifting news
oh yeah there are going to be
catastrophic consequences to climate
change is we now the pit works wait for
it Hank okay if we do not dramatically
decrease carbon emissions so as to limit
global warming to 1.5 degrees Celsius
over pre-industrial levels but but but
but if you go to euronews com you'll
discover I'm just gonna quote from the
story Hank while Britain's scorching
summer has left some concerned about
global warming
England's sparkling wine industry has
seen its best ever harvest all right
that's right Hank forget champagne down
there in France England is the next hot
spot for sparkling wine the conditions
said Mark Harvey managing director of
the wines business at Chapel down have
been frankly perfect well I mean I'm not
saying that there's not gonna be maybe
some good news from global warming like
it I live in a very cold place a less
less harsh winter would would be
appreciated it's just going to be a
little bit more fires II
yeah the fire season was gonna have more
of the fire part well let's answer some
questions for my listeners because I
have no comfort to offer you this
question comes from Delaney who writes
Dear John and Hank I just started
listening to your podcast last week and
so far I'm a huge fan thanks for that
qualified vote of confidence Delaney I
work at amaze what I work at amaze
okay I work at a Maine and today it was
my job to clean it out wait what
double why those a dirty maze what okay
I was given a map to help me go through
it but there's an issue I don't know how
to read a map I've been in this two
point seven mile maze wait what wait
Hank
Google two point seven mile maze and try
to figure out where we are right now in
the world okay I've been at a two point
seven mile maze for over an hour and I'm
starting to get nervous question mark
should I call my boss or just keep on
wandering until I find my way out or
should I just follow a family that looks
really confident
I think you've definitely figured out
the solution uh
it appears to me John yeah there's only
one maze one corn maze that is two point
seven miles that I have found yeah no
there's two okay there's two so it's
either the Bela organic pumpkin patch
yeah in Sauvie Island 13 miles from
downtown Portland or it's the MLB two
PDX corn maze oh no that's the same one
it's the same one oh I see I see I see a
two point seven mile corn maze in
Massachusetts on sawchuck farm okay so
it might be that - turns out there's a
surprising number of two point seven
mile corn mazes in America for those of
you who don't know the United States let
me introduce you to a crazy idea what if
a country grew so much corn that it
intentionally destroyed some of that
corn in order to build a maze because
our corn is now tall enough that we
can't see over the top of it and so it's
now a Halloween tradition
I don't know they don't have that in
other places that's just an American
thing we do have a lot of corn here I
don't know we're it's a corn heavy
economy here in the u.s. Delaney you're
going to follow a family and at some
point they're going to turn to you and
say may I help you and you say I work
here and then hopefully they'll be cool
with it and you're gonna make your way
out of the maze ultimately that's isn't
that worse to be like I work here I am
lost you know what I I do what I'm lost
in a corn maze I have done this on a
couple of occasions I just start plowing
through court and that is ultimately
always an option that's the nice thing
about corn mazes you can walk through
corn just like you can walk through a
cornfield and ultimately you'll be able
to get out of the thing if it comes to
that but but I mean at least you're
getting a lot of good cleaning done
unless you just sort of like walking
around the same loop over and over again
which is totally possible because it
appears that this corn maze has a
baseball in it
oh what a large baseball like if you
look at it from the sky oh you're
looking at a large baseball that has
been drawn and you might just go around
that baseball hoop a bunch and then
you're gonna get out of the corn maze
and your boss is gonna be like so did
you clean every bit of the corn maze and
you're gonna be like I have no idea
I need a GPS yeah like I listen
it's 2018 don't hand me a paper map this
person was almost certainly born in the
21st century like they've probably never
held a paper map before Delaney probably
like got the map and was like what is
this physical last experience I'm being
asked to have why also why are people
being so disrespectful to the maze that
you need to clean it so finally can we
just all agree to clean up after
ourselves when we're inside of a maze
and now let's do a question from Kaylee
who asks dear Hank and John my boyfriend
won't register to vote he turned 18 in
December and ever since his birthday
I've been telling him at the register he
says he won't because his voice doesn't
matter oh oh I was wondering if you
could try to convince him to vote and
educate him on the importance of the
matter PS he said that if you answered
the question he would
register I just recently introduced him
to the pot and he's in love sincerely
just Kaylie well I guess we did it we're
done
boom yeah but here's why you register to
vote because all of the people who say
my voice doesn't matter add up to like
40 or 50 percent of the electorate and
if they voted if they understood that
their individual voice is part of a
larger collective if they voted then we
would have better governance that more
closely reflected the actual values of
the United States so it's not just about
you it's about you have the community
that you live in I think that we can get
really caught up in individualism in
America we're an individualist country
and I don't think that there's anything
wrong with like people understanding
that them as one person can really
change and affect the world but I also
like I've always thought of this as like
if if like if the the cognitive whatever
that is in the way of me voting is also
in the way of other people voting like
this kind of for me an effect where like
if I get over that then I assume that
other people will and we will together
be an important part of the electorate
and I know that that's abstract and I
don't know how much it reflects reality
but that's how I feel I feel like me
like figuring out how to get myself to
engage with the process is in a way like
reflected in lots of other people who
are going through those same not mind
things and so like we are together doing
a thing that is going to be important it
is going to change things yeah I
completely agree the last thing I'll say
about this is that when you vote you are
not just voting for yourself and for
your community you're also voting in a
way that's going to affect things for
lots of people who can't vote because US
policymakers shape lots of things
outside of the United States so yeah
please vote please vote please make a
plan to vote if you're worried about
whether you're gonna vote get an
accountability partner text a friend and
say you and I are going to figure out
this voting thing together vote
sometimes people will say to me that
that it's all about the corporations and
they're the ones with the power but
while they can spend money trying to
change the outcome of elections they
can't vote that they can influence the
people but the people were the ones who
decide and that means your boyfriend
Kaylie corporations can also try to keep
people from voting try to discourage
people from voting and let me submit
that well I've heard from a lot of young
people that they think they're sticking
it to the man somehow by not voting the
only way to actually stick it to the man
is to do what they don't want you to do
which is vote okay moving on this next
question is from Ryan sorry I got a
little emotional here John and Hank I've
recently been invited to an art gallery
with a friend I haven't seen for a year
how do you make an entertaining and
respectful companion in an art gallery
wooo-oooo this is actually one of my
areas of expertise yeah I I never go to
art galleries unless it's with someone
I'm quite close to I don't know III need
your help John I also need help with
this that seems like a weird friend date
I love it as a friend date or as a
romantic date because it's a chance to
hang out together and share an
experience and you can have conversation
but you can also have quiet time Ryan I
would err on the side of quiet
especially if you don't know a lot about
art the first time I went to an art
gallery was when I had a crush on Sarah
and she was managing a gallery in
Chicago and she was like we have a an
art opening you should come and so I did
and I went alone and first off there was
free wine which I felt like I'd hacked
the system there was free wine
everywhere and then I went to like a
different gallery that was on a
different floor of the same building and
there was free wine there and I was like
does this just go on all night and it
does anyway what I would do Ryan is I
would listen listen if the person that
you're with knows more about art than
you do listen and then respond to what
they say rather than like offering your
own opinions or if you do offer your own
opinions make them impressionistic don't
try to seem smart just try to just right
respond to the art the way that you
respond to it emotionally or
intellectually don't try to seem like
you know about art but
cuz down that path lies ruin yeah yeah
and you know I that's that's something
that I had to come to terms with as as
he as an appreciator of art like that
I'm not here that that like the value
that I can provide in in terms of like
like having an emotion about a piece of
creation is not like my critique it's
not like within the context of
everything that I know it's like I like
that why do I like that what is it that
I like about that or I don't like that
or like I didn't like it at first but
then now I'm starting to like it or I
like it from far away but close up I
don't like it as much so letting my
opinions happen and then doing a little
bit of analysis for why it's more about
me than it is about like trying to
understand what art is and that helped
me a lot
in sort of getting over the pretension
that I sometimes think we can feel about
art yep I totally agree
so thanks for helping me work through
that John well I'm happy to do it if I
can this next question comes from Laura
who writes dear John and Hank I'm making
spaghetti and I'm curious about the most
efficient way to boil water when I'm
filling the pot with water from my sink
is it more or less energy efficient for
me to use the hot water tap what about
if I fill my spaghetti pot with water
from my electric kettle which is nearly
boiling thanks for your advice on this
incredibly pressing matter
Laura mmm it depends I actually know
about this John I know the actual answer
to this question so it's not I also know
the answer Oh are we gonna have to brag
I'll fight about it well there is only
one answer which is that you use cold
water from the tap that you then heat on
the stovetop yeah probably that's more
efficient it if you're talking about
because because of course the hot water
that comes out of your tap comes from
your hot water heater which was also
heated your hot water heater is probably
more efficient than your stovetop is but
in the process of getting from your hot
water heater to your tap you probably
lose a lot of energy warming up the
pipes and stuff so it's probably better
to put it but it might not be it depends
like it's pretty close
but your kettle is definitely more
efficient than your stove at heating
water so this is actually I do this all
the time it's also faster I heat water
in my electric kettle and then I pour it
into my pot and then he'll then like use
the pot to do the like the last little
bit of boiling it and that I that is
more efficient because kettles are
better at heating water and it's also
faster because kettles are better at
heating water okay Hank it's the rare
occasion when you actually have helpful
life hacks this next question comes from
Nicole I'm just gonna keep asking them
dear John and Hank I was recently at
Hanks book tour in Milwaukee afterwards
when I returned to my car someone had
broken my car window Nicole I feel
personally responsible for this oh wait
no I wasn't at the show in Milwaukee
Nicole this is Hanks fault they didn't
take anything and insurance covered the
fix so it wasn't more than an
inconvenience but as soon as I noticed I
called my mom to ask what to do I'm 25
years old and I've always thought of
myself as independent my question is
this why don't we teach that the
mitochondria is the powerhouse of the
cell but not how to navigate occurrences
that we may run into in our daily lives
when will I finally hit the point in my
life where I don't have to call my mom
every time something new happens
somebody are to use my name specific
sign-off Nicole well well the answer is
that you you will always have people in
your life that you'll go to when you're
confused about how to handle a situation
and that might be like a work thing it
might be a logistical like insurance
claim thing it might be like your last
will and testament like you need people
to help you through stuff and we're all
always learning and I think part of the
reason why we don't learn that stuff in
school is because one it changes a lot
like different insurance companies are
different and two it's so much stuff and
and like knowing what it's going to be
for every individual person like we're
never gonna know life is gonna throw
different curveballs to different people
but knowing the mitochondria is the
powerhouse of the cell that's gonna come
in handy every day yeah I think that's
one of the things that's hard about
teaching a personal finance class in
high school yeah right is that personal
finance is different for almost everyone
and it depends upon many many different
variables
I remember I called my dad shortly after
my son was born and asked him at what
point he felt like I became like a net
asset in terms of being able to provide
more solutions and opportunities than
you know problems for him specifically
yeah and he was like I'll let you know
when it happens
you could still more work than you're
worth John yeah which I appreciated and
also think was very true so I don't know
how to answer your question really
because I definitely have not gotten to
that place of sustainable independence
yet and I also think I may never get
there and I also think they call that
like you would have found a way to
figure it out if you had to and like
this was just the most convenient way
that you had at the moment and you know
ultimately having someone anyone there
to be a help is always really nice and
so it just be thankful that you have
that this next question comes from
Alison who writes dear Jon Hank my
roommate and I recently moved out of an
apartment and we went our separate ways
she left about a month before I did and
purposefully left some things behind
like a lamp and a cello she never
learned to play Alison I'm sensing a bit
of animosity I don't like to read emails
for tone but I feel like maybe this
didn't have its best possible ending in
terms of a roommate relationship the
lamp I obviously would have some use for
but what do I do with this cello now
that I'm into my new place do I try and
teach myself how to play the cello do I
give it to the next person I live with
should I sell it and donate the money to
help decrease worldsuck
please help a fellow with a cello Alison
Alison I don't know if if I'm just
projecting a personal experience here
but have you ever like purchased like
for example say a drum set and then it
sits in the corner of your office for
like five years and you've played it
like two times and you look at it every
once in a while and you're like I should
probably do that and then but it kind of
becomes like an object of resentment a
little bit because he it's like that
that thing that I wanted to have
happened is never going to have
been and to the point where like maybe
if you move out you're like I'm just
gonna leave that drum set there because
that that it is just makes me sad now if
the how it happened with the cello yeah
of course that's what happened with the
cello but we're not here to
psychoanalyze Alison's former roommate
we're here to deal with the cello and
the correct way to deal with the cello
is of course to put it very prominently
on a cello stand in this whatever the
central room of your new apartment is so
whenever you have a visitor they come in
and the first thing they see is the
cello and they say oh do you play the
cello and you say no or or what about
the long con John I don't know what your
long con is gonna be but here's my
initial thought about the long con what
if alison invests extremely heavily in
cello lessons four to five hours of
cello per day for years and years and
years Alison gets so good at the cello
she starts playing for the Milwaukee
Symphony Orchestra I'm assuming that
there is such a thing and then she
invites her ex-roommate to the opening
show of Ardath Vern Beethoven's 17th
cello symphony there in front of the
whole symphony just Alison cranking in
front of an audience of exactly one
because yeah it's it's the night before
the actual opening and it's just
Alison's ex-roommate and it's like you
know how you never cleaned the dishes
while you left your cello and I just
started noodling around and Here I am
the greatest cello player in all of
Wisconsin is Milwaukee and Wisconsin it
is how was your tour visit there doesn't
seem like you went particularly deep oh
god it's such a bit like I have never I
mean I got home from tour and my wallet
was bulging with a little bag receipt
tags that you're supposed to hold on to
in case they lose your bag yeah at like
35 of them well yeah I mean you went on
16 or 17
airplane flights in 13 days it was gone
crazy that's why I like to travel the
country in a bus yeah that sounds nice
the tour was a complete whirlwind and I
was only on half of it and I even though
it was a week ago I remember almost
nothing but I do have one extremely
vivid memory Hank which is that in
Canton Ohio you and I went to a
restaurant that was also a bar that was
also a honky-tonk that had big windows
named George's yeah that definitely
happened George's was the only
restaurant open in Canton Ohio when our
show ended we went there and it was the
best restaurant and experience I have
ever had in my entire life
I loved it very much at the end of the
night we hadn't finished our pretzel
bites and the waitress was like oh do
you want me to discount those and we
were like that's not that's not how this
works
she's like you basically only ate a half
order and we were like we bought the
whole order though like that's what
happens that's that's how buying food
works I drank as many Miller Lites as I
wished to have I ate like a king and our
tab was if I recall correctly $36 I also
got to enjoy live music there were four
of us to be clear there were kale chips
there were kale chips yeah and and at
the end of the night there our New York
City publicist was like I think that
there's been a problem with the pills
yeah no she inquired about the bill
because she felt that it was too low and
honestly I agreed with her for that
level of entertainment I would expect to
pay thirty eight or even thirty nine
dollars yeah anybody near Canton go on
over see George's we actually saw
several people several nerdfighters
inside George's yeah we did we do who
were like hey what the heck are you
doing in George's which reminds me that
today's podcast is brought to you by
George's George's it's in Canton Ohio
and it has no windows no it was very
confusing when we first arrived we were
like are we going into a place this
podcast is also brought to you by
Nicole's mom dot-com where you can go
to get life tips and advice from
Nicole's mom why don't why isn't that a
thing Tom just wow that is a really
violent insurance claim Hank of all of
the terrible million dollar ideas you've
ever had that is an actually good idea
[Laughter]
you just call when you're confused about
something you're like I've been in a car
accident and they're like here's how it
works today's podcast has also brought
to you by Hanks electric kettle Hanks
electric kettle it is more efficient
than gas stove heat and finally this
podcast is brought to you by Bella
organic pumpkin patch 2.7 miles of
spotless maize thanks Delaney thanks
Delaney we also have a personal message
to read from somebody who donated the
project for awesome that somebody is
Bryan in Omaha Nebraska who wrote this
message for Nina you are an incredible
woman and sometimes things might be
tough in a new place but I can think of
no person better able to handle
obstacles than you so there you go Nina
I hope that helps John we got another
question it's from Carl who asks dear
Hank and John I recently finished an
absolutely remarkable thing available
now wherever books are sold and I really
enjoyed it there's a problem however as
a person named Carl the book was
exceptionally more weird than I think
Hank intended I intended it to be pretty
weird do you have any advice on how to
get the intended reading experience out
of a book in which all the characters
are constantly talking about the
existential impact of my existence on
the human species not 10 foot tall robot
from New York Carl I I mean it would be
a weird reading experience to be named
Carl because people are talking about
you in really big ways you know they got
a lot of opinions about you big opinions
it reminds me of the recent tweets from
from Sean Spicer but not Sean Spicer and
Brett Kavanaugh but not Brett Kavanaugh
and how their dislike no need to have a
support group for this and Sara Sanders
is like yeah I'm feeling yeah Brett
Kavanaugh the Twitter user is a very
funny Twitter user like he's very
charming but his most recent tweet on
October
went viral it was this is a terrible
time to be named Brett Kavanaugh well
he's like he's it's spelled very
slightly different but uh yeah I think
if people aren't being careful also
today on on Twitter hurricane Michael is
trending but hurricane is spelled wrong
in the trending page and I'm just like
well I guess that's where we're at
yeah it's never fun to have a hurricane
named after you either so shout out to
our dad who is having to struggle with
being a famous hurricane right now I'm
sorry Mike
yeah Karl I would take it as good news
that Hank has chosen to lift your name
up in this way and just lean into it be
like yeah I am a Karl you are a Karl
live live your carelessness next
question comes from Emma who asks dear
Hank and John I'm a college freshman
living my on my own for the first time
so far as living with five other people
can be called living on my own now that
I'm out of the house that I'm confronted
with a predicament I've never given much
thought before where does the silverware
go we share a number of things between
us one of them two silverware and that's
been vanishing at a remarkable rate I
hope you can help us with this dilemma
dill Emma a very good very good Emma
very good thing I have not lost
silverware yeah
in the last 12 years but you have the
same silverware set since we got married
12 years ago exactly me too and we have
not needed to like replenish it or
anything no however in the 12 years
before that I would estimate that I lost
every fork I ever encountered it's gotta
be the roommates right nobody's
respecting the property because it's all
shared property well although in my case
I was the roommate but you needed you
needed somebody in a house who you
really had to like maintain a strong
relationship with like because you were
married to them who would who would
force you to be more respectful of the
cutlery I remember I moved out of one
apartment and as I was moving out I
found like a plate underneath my bed
that just had like two forks and what
must have been 17 year old fried rice
Oh God this is the problem this is this
is what's occurring yeah so Emma the
good news is that there's no way your
rice is 17 years old because it's your
only 19 or 18 it could be worse
yeah oh I was such a filthy person god I
mean I want to go back like whenever I
think about early 20s me all I can
picture is like holding a hose with
extremely high water pressure and like
just washing that person Oh stain their
clothes yeah in their clothes just being
like in your head do like their mental
health as well needs a good high
pressure spray yeah oh god I was a wreck
yeah you were much love to my roommates
from that era we're actually having a
reunion soon
and I'm so excited but at the same time
I'm like I can't believe these people
are willing to be in my company again
Jonna I have another silverware related
question that I thought was a question I
was asking but it turns out that we had
good answers to both of them this one
comes from Alvaro who asks dear Hank and
John I was having lunch and while
looking at the fork I was using I
wondered why aren't forks Trident shaped
why did we need to add that extra point
why did we stop at four points any
dubious advice as to why I insert this
miniature weapon into my mouth on a
daily basis is greatly appreciated love
the show Alvaro Hank I actually know the
answer to this question
okay what's the answer to the question
so when we first started using Forks in
around like 1500 they only had two times
how about these guys like yeah look like
a turkey fork when you're dirt carving
Turkey
yeah because every new time that you
would create was extra work so you
wanted to use the minimum number of
chair that make sense the problem was
that people would stab themselves like
they would it sounds extremely dangerous
as soon as you said that I was like ow I
don't want to put that in my mouth I
would stab the roof of their mouths they
would you know
get it stuck between there's all kinds
of problems and so they were like maybe
we should have a third tine and they did
and then they were like you know what
might be better a fourth time and it was
and then they were like you know it
might be better a fit and then everyone
was like no that's worse it was it's the
exact same thing as with razors like
remember how razors for all of human
history had two blades and then the Mach
3 came out and everyone was like oh my
god three blades on one razor this is
revolute know if the lots people weren't
alive for this but like it was as close
to a consumer product revolution as I
have witnessed in my lifetime except
maybe the people were adoption of the
personal computer they were so excited
people were so like it was like it was
such an event and it's so very strange
to think back now at what an event it
was rather than a third blade to the
Mach 3 I remember reading about it in
Time magazine and like not in an
advertisement but like in an article
yeah yeah man we cared about things that
are different back then so anyway then
everybody had three blades and one day
somebody was like now we're gonna
release a razor with four blades and it
didn't make quite as big of a splash and
then somebody was like now we're gonna
release a race with five blades and
everyone was like actually this is worse
like let's go back to the Mach 3 like
that yeah good number of blades and
that's exactly what happened with Forks
oh I wonder if it's the fits the if like
it's the use of the fork we're having
five times is like and that doesn't work
as well or if having five times it's
like I just that looks like too many it
looks like a hand it looks like a human
hand I'm not trying to increase me and
I'll try to employ a tiny child to feed
me I just want to use a fork yeah it's
like a weird robot child's arm that I've
played in Google Google Fork with five
times and tell me you've ever seen
anything uglier like I am
[Music]
why is that so creepy I'm nauseated like
that barfi Oh God reminds me of Bart
Simpson's head oh I don't like that one
either that's so strange why would my
like that oh well there you go there's
your answer they're disgusting fine
sports are horrifying
they are they look very oh my gosh
woof I don't know why I don't like it I
don't though we don't like it we don't
like it all right this next question
comes from Kate Hank who writes Dear
John and Hank I've recently started
adding more vintage style pieces to my
wardrobe you've come to the right place
for advice Kate I mean we are well known
but I actually have a column in vogue
I'd like to complete my outfits with
hats but hats that are not beanies or
ball caps are just not as popular as
they used to be should i flaunt
ridiculous early 20th century hats in
style or keep it subtle and leave the
feathers ribbons and flowers behind not
the one with the amazing Titanic hat
Kate John when you said that you had a
column in vogue I honestly pictured that
like they took a picture of a part of
your house that had a column in it and
that was in vogue and I was like that's
believable why would that be weird
well first off that implies that I'm
married to the kind of person who would
ever ever purchase a home with a column
in it I don't know I I realize I've
alienated a huge percentage of our
audience with that but it's true I mean
Sarah okay there's maybe five things in
the world that Sarah is more opposed to
than exterior columns on a home she
likes the interior one flow just like a
big pillar well I mean you know you need
something to hold up a house sure sure
no Sarah Sarah loves a clean line yeah
and case of five time to fork though I
mean if you showed that to Sarah she
would she might barf
I thought I was gonna barf a little bit
I was trying to move on I was trying to
move on to Kate's issue Kate I think you
should go hard on hats man I think you
should I think we should go as big as
you want to go and then you dial it back
as you need to because once you have the
Hat go feathers go flowers and then if
you're like oh this a little bit much
then you can just go hat it's easier to
take away that it is to add Shay
sure that's what everybody says about
that phrase I guess I guess actually in
the case of feathers it is pretty easy
to do either I yeah
so we have another question that's from
Ashley that's similar about wanting to
wear lapel pins like enamel pins but not
you're having like not feeling like she
looks good in a jean jacket or is a jean
jacket person yeah
Oh or like she wants to be a jean jacket
person but she doesn't feel like she is
I've read the same way and then I wore a
jean jacket for like two days and
suddenly I was a jean jacket person it's
like you just like you have to like do
the thing to see if you're that thing
and maybe like you aren't until you are
and maybe you're maybe if you're not
like a fancy hat and maybe the world
isn't gonna accept that until you do it
and then they have to I didn't wear blue
jeans for 11 years
oh I'm gonna sign up the phone what's
wrong with you what that's very confused
this is in the same period by the way
when I was losing a lot of Forks I only
wore like khaki pants with pleats like
pleated khaki pants oh God one day my
roommate Hassan was like you need to
wear blue jeans and I was like nah man
I'm not a blue jeans person I I haven't
worn blue jeans in 11 years and he said
blue jeans are comfortable and I said no
I don't like I don't like that if I
don't like to feel him I don't like
names like we're going to the store and
you're gonna buy some blue jeans and I
put on a pair of blue jeans and I was
like these are great oh my god and I
literally have not taken off jeans in
the in app 12 years since I recently not
recently within the last 10 years put on
a pair of pleated khaki pants and came
out of
dressing room to show Catherine the
pants that I liked and she was she said
no never not that and I was like what
they're just cat and she's like you're
not wearing pleated khaki pants ever
ever and I was like I don't know what
this means she's like you don't have to
just don't do it I got I get the same
response from Sara and I know lots of
people out there love pleated khaki
pants and I say love them love it with
your whole heart but Sara died briefly
dated before we ended up dating for good
and the only thing that sara wrote about
me in her journal from the first time
that we hung out was that I was wearing
pleated khaki pants there's no no review
of the date at all because it wasn't
necessary because the date was reviewed
by my pants like she didn't need any
extra information encapsulated
everything that's so great that's
wonderful I also like I'm gonna shift
back to Ashley's question which was
actually she said she can't wear jean
jackets and she wants to know how to
wear an ammo pins first I think you can
pull off a jean jacket Ashley second I
put him in my backpacks I put him in my
guitar strap I put them on hoodies
sometimes I'm wearing a hoodie right now
with with a little Mars Pathfinder pin
and yeah I think you can pin a pin on
pretty much anything these days not
anything like not your dog
oh sorry yeah no I mean any item of
clothing or anything made of fabric
don't don't just like jam it into your
knee yeah you know people take the
advice of this podcast very seriously
Hank that's my bad that's my bad I
should be more I should be more open and
clear with my language Hank before we
get to the all-important news from Mars
and AFC Wimbledon it's we have one
vitally important update from Katie who
you'll remember once I read the email
Dear John and Hank I just listened do
you answer my question about whether or
not I should go to a theme park with my
long-lost friend and her dad and I felt
the need to update you I did go it was
okay my friend was glued to her phone
the entire time but when her phone died
she was actually quite interesting that
might be my most favorite sentence in
the
goosh language that will also be true of
the human race
[Laughter]
aye-aye
I feel like I should have that sentence
printed out tattooed on the inside of my
wrist and then I should never get on the
internet again we talked a lot about
college stuff and whether or not books
are better than movies and her dad was
ok but kind of eccentric and terrified
of rides so that was fun I guess
also I've been stuck with a severe case
of writer's block for literally years
and your comparison to this experience
being a young adult novel gave me a
great idea
much love Katy Katy I cannot wait for
your novel about this experience that
goes it's gold it's gold Katie I you
know what I was thinking the other day
Hank I was thinking about your book
which has been on my mind constantly
since I read it and I was thinking that
it I used to feel when I was younger
like experiences I had were incomplete
until I shared them with the people I
loved the most and in a way experiencing
things alone especially wonderful things
was partly enjoyable because I knew that
I would tell people about them later or
I would share those memories later and
now instead of needing to share
something with the people I love in
order for it to feel real I have to
share it with everyone yeah I feel that
way about thoughts sometimes like it's
not a real thought unless I've gotten to
a place where it can be shared with a
large audience yeah
and that kind of limits the the the
number of thoughts that I feel like are
thinkable yeah yeah I'm close to the
edge on the Internet Hank I'm close I'm
close to I'm I'm we'll bring you back
around yeah no I feel like I feel like I
have had a much more extreme response to
your book than you have I feel like you
maybe didn't read the parts that were
about how good the internet can be yeah
but none of those experiences occur on
an open Internet that is owned and
controlled by a few extremely large
companies
all right let's get to the all-important
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon Hank
what is the news from Mars this week
come on little Rover I don't have any I
don't have any I just don't have
whatever reason I don't have any
opportunity news this week we'll talk
about it next week maybe uh but but I do
have Mars 2020 Rover news John oh good
so they are they have completed the
chassis like the big box where all the
things go and gets bolted onto and
that's the very important part of the
step of the process of creating this
this big big giant Rover and the Jet
Propulsion Laboratory has released a
very good and interesting story about
how they paint this thing so they got
they have they paint it it's just it's
aluminum and the process of painting it
is surprisingly manual and because you
know it's not like they're gonna make
more than one of them and also it is
painted by a guy who paints cars so
that's how he learned how to paint
things and he will like he does like
pinstriping and flames on cars and
motorcycles
he's even painted guitars in his in his
career as a painter and so like this guy
you know started out being a dude who
customizes the hot hot cars and now
works with a small team and and paints
various spacecraft in addition to also
steel painting cars so he this it's a
great story you can find it just like
painting cars for Mars is the JPL story
and you find out a lot like the lot of
process goes into this process and they
also have to tape so like the parts that
they don't want to get painted no like
so cuz they're gonna be like we're riot
wires they're running over stuffs gonna
get bolted onto the rover they tape it
with masking tape like just tape you can
buy at the hardware store except that
they have that tape like laser-cut buy a
thing to make it exactly the right shape
before they put it on so that's
it was fascinating to hear how like one
very small step of the process for how
to get a rover ready to go to Mars works
and and the you know people necessary to
make that all happen that is really cool
is it gonna launch in 2020 or is it
gonna get there in 2020 it's gonna
launch in 2020 or that is the plan at
least well I mean I feel like when you
name it the Mars 2020 Rover you're
really committing to a timeline it will
have a different name by the time it
launches like there it's like if Elon
Musk called the Tesla Model 3 that Tesla
2017 yeah would have been a problem yeah
that's that's they they'll come up with
some some fancier name like spirit
opportunity curiosity by the time it
launches but they just that's this
that's the sort of like working
operating title right now what's a good
value along with curiosity opportunity
that you could name it careful careful
the Mars careful Rover there's a rock
there got careful jeez don't drive it
into the dirt I want to I want to create
a Twitter bot that does nothing but
respond to every single tweet written by
every single person all day long
with the word careful that's a lot maybe
rethink that
just give it a lot careful you sure you
want to share that careful pink the news
from AFC Wimbledon is terrible
unrelentingly terrible Wimbledon loss to
Plymouth Argyle who are the worst team
in league one we also lost one nil to
Bradford City who are one of the worst
teams in Ligue 1 ha there's a lot of
talk these days about change and weather
change is necessary Wimbledon of course
have had the same manager Neal art Lee a
hero for the club played for the club
when he was a boy for the now I think
six or seven years saw us you know rise
up from Ligue 2 to leave one to helped
us secure survival in Ligue 2 in our
first year when we almost went back down
to non-league football so
Oh Neal art Lee has been an amazing
manager for Wimbledon that said the
situation is pretty bleak right now not
a lot of goals not a lot of excitement
not a lot of optimism women are just
outside of the relegation zone in 20th
place 21st through 24th will be
relegated to League to the fourth tier
of English football so maybe there's a
spot of hope in that but oh yeah yeah
yeah it's not great that's good and you
got a lot of of like season left so is
there stuff you can change now that can
affect that yeah the biggest thing that
gets changed generally in these
situations is the manager though you
know so I think that's it's just a
difficult here's the truth it is really
hard to run a football club effectively
on a budget Wimbledon has one of the
lowest budgets in the Football League
that's hard it's always going to be hard
and I think to an extent with the
current budget there's a ceiling of how
well Wimbledon can do and in a way
they're passed that ceiling and so it's
always gonna be really hard in the third
tier unless you know I don't know so I
don't know I I feel very conflicted
about it
I like knee largely a lot but I also
understand how frustrated the fans are
well I I don't know how to fix football
teams but I do know that you guys have
got the passion and you're gonna have
your new home and that's all gonna be
good for the long-term of the club yep
we just got to get to it we got to get
to plough Lane got to get back to plough
Lane Hank thank you for potting with me
it's always a pleasure I even when
you're sick yeah I'm sorry that I I'm so
raspy and oh I'm not loving I prefer it
I prefer I like having coffee breaks
okay good glad I could be there for you
this podcast is edited by Nicholas
Jenkins incredibly hard-working Nicholas
Jenkins dealing not only with COFF
bricks but just with our shenanigans in
general it's produced by rosianna halse
rojas and sheridan
and our head of community and
communications is Victoria Bonjour know
the music that you're listening to now
and also the beginning of the podcast is
by the great gunnarolla thank you again
for listening and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]